it's been almost four months since
President Trump announced his intention
to end daca that's Barack Obama's
program that hands out work permits to
illegal immigrants who arrived in this
country as minors since that time
lawmakers have been trying to hammer out
a plan that would protect daca
beneficiaries from being deported now
trying to cut a deal is reasonable but
amnesty should only be given in return
for real and long-term immigration
reforms otherwise will amount to yet
another betrayal the kind that voters
have seen many times over the past
thirty years the kind nikhat Donald
Trump elected in the first place
actually America deserves real borders
and policies that put American interests
first instead of an endless cycle of
amnesty coupled with empty promises of
future border enforcement at some point
and that's what we've had for a long
time united behind stricter immigration
laws should not be a heavy lift for the
Republican Party for one thing Americans
want it they want it badly
we know that because a new poll by
numbers USA asked likely voters have
they felt about various aspects of our
immigration policy and the answer
sounded a lot like a trump campaign
speech consider chain migration 57% of
likely voters said that if daca
beneficiaries get amnesty they shouldn't
be allowed to bring their family members
here just 31 percent of voters disagreed
with that how about the diversity
lottery that's the program that selects
50,000 people every year to enter the
United States gives them visas they're
selected pretty much at random without
regard to any qualifications including
English knowledge or job skills or
cultural fit 60% of voters said the
diversity visa lottery ought to be
abolished entirely only 29% supported it
and then there's Avera phi that's the
program that allows employers to check
the legal status of people they're gonna
hire fifty seven percent of likely
voters say Congress should require you
verify for all hiring so that employers
can't claim ignorance when they hire
illegals just 23 percent disagreed with
that and voters aren't just opposed to
illegal immigration by the way a strong
majority wants to cut all immigration
including legal across-the-board
currently this country bets about a mil
in legal immigrants a year 60% of those
to ask said they'd like to cut that
number in half if not more in political
terms those numbers are huge
Republicans would kill for that kind of
support on other issues all kinds of
other issues restricting immigration is
a lot pop more popular for example than
defunding Planned Parenthood or cutting
taxes for the wealthier cracking down on
marijuana bombing distant countries more
popular than all of that it's also of
course the main thing that President
Trump ran on last year and probably the
central reason he won in that upset
victory this should not be hard just a
month ago the Republicans United to pass
an unpopular tax reform bill they should
be able to come together to pass a far
more popular form of immigration reform
it's somehow that's not happening in
fact the opposite is happening
apparently a number of Republican
senators are prepared to cave completely
to Democrats on this question agreeing
to amnesty with no serious concessions
in return one proposal would simply
delay chain migration rather than ending
it while expanding the scope of the
amnesty for daca recipients and
reallocating diversity lottery visas to
a different class of unskilled
immigrants not only would a deal like
that hurt the country voters have said
very clearly again and again they don't
want it and this is a democracy after
all or at least it was you have to
listen to what voters want if you're a
lawmaker if you see that kind of deal
come out of Congress and you may the
Republican Party is done it's over it's
toast it'll be a short epitaph to
suicide congressman Sean Duffy is a
Republican representing Wisconsin and he
joins us thank congressman thank you for
coming on say Tucker it's good to be
with you happy new year
the happy new year so these poll numbers
are really striking to me because they
show that the public is tougher on
immigration including legal immigration
even maybe then the current president
was during the campaign and I'm
wondering if this news is filtered down
to Republicans in the Congress who seem
way more liberal on immigration than
their voters oh listen figure I don't
know that the Congress is actually that
liberal East the Republicans aren't that
liberal in Congress now we do have some
outliers that wouldn't my
having a dhaka amnesty fixed without any
border security or any fix of chain
migration that's true but a vast
majority Republicans in the Congress we
stand with President Trump we want to we
want to fix the situation we have with
the daca kids we think that's reasonable
and fair but in exchange for that we
want to secure a border we want to build
a wall we want to fix chain migration we
want to fix the lottery system so I
gotta tell you what if Democrats don't
start to negotiate fairly on this issue
they will know there'll be no deal for
the docket kids so I listen I get your
concern but I got to tell you what I
said inside our Republican conferences
and there's a great unity around this
issue of fixing the root cause the
problem that continues to bring new
people in who technically just pack
their bags and they decide to come in to
our country on their own where we
believe that Americans have a right to
pick and choose who comes into our
country one we want the people that
graduate from MIT and Harvard that love
America or even the people that will
come and work up on our Wisconsin dairy
farms where those are jobs that our own
people won't take we need those kind of
people who love to work in love our
country but we get to pick and choose
them you just don't get a pack a bag and
come across the border and say you're
gonna be yeah so the president runs this
campaign that's different from the 17
other campaigns Republicans are running
really in one respect he's tough on
immigration he says he wants to build a
wall were a year in Republicans have
unified to pass an unpopular tax bill
they tried to get health care through
they've done all manner of things they
haven't actually gotten together to do
that the one thing he ran on why is that
so listen I hate to get in the weeds
with you but you know that we could pass
a funding bill for the wall in the house
but we can't pass that kind of bill in
the Senate though Republicans control
the Senate they have this thing called
the filibuster rule you need 60 votes
which means nine Democrats have to vote
for that funding that becomes very
challenging for us so I would love if
Republicans could ram through a funding
bill for the wall but that's just not
the reality of politics in the Senate so
we're gonna have to leverage daca in
exchange for border security and other
immigration reforms that's just the way
the Senate and so any of you should get
but that's the truth so just to get to
one of the key questions in that
negotiation
and chain migration so I think most
people look at this and say you know you
came into the country illegally maybe
your parents brought you here maybe you
came isn't unaccompanied minor but it's
illegal you shouldn't be allowed to
bring all your relatives with you
what percentage would you say if
Republicans disagree with that statement
in the house I think a vast majority
agree with the fact that this if you're
a Dockett child you should be able to
bring in your parents through migration
but let me just take a step back
Tucker Democrats want these children to
become citizens within five years and
then through chain migration be able to
bring bring their parents into the
country legally who brought them the
child in unlawfully this is insane
listen Republicans aren't going to stand
for their if to your point
Republicans might not have run an
immigration reform but the poll numbers
that you cited and the success of Donald
Trump have made it very clear that we
can have a stronger backbone and
actually fight for immigration reform
that works for the country and that's
one of the benefits of Trump and him
driving a message about equity equity
and fairness in immigration reform so I
think this the Republicans are going to
are gonna hold the line and just if they
don't and I think we will but if they
don't Donald Trump won't sign any
legislation that doesn't have a border
wall funding component to it he's not
gonna mean I really don't know the
answer but I do know I'm totally
convinced we got Trump in the first
place because Congress ignored what
voters wanted for like 30 years and I
made people mad come on thank you for
coming on
okay thanks doctor